one of my videos went viral for me hit
almost 2 000 views but I can't get back
to those views again is that typical
the after you've seen a video do well
you want to follow up we say success
leaves Clues make part twos you want to
follow up not with a duplicate video but
with an adjacent video what topic went
viral for me how can you double down on
that topic and maybe turn it into a
series what can you learn from it but
then it also it could be typical because
sometimes it's hard to replicate success
this is one of the reasons why we have
uh launched our VRA Elite program which
is like group coaching we now have think
media certified coaches because it's
also hard to sometimes observe our own
content from an objective standpoint
because what you also want to do is you
want to
architect you want to um pull out the
principles if you you meaning you go I
don't know why this went viral that
would be the big question to to figure
out what about it and vfm viral for me
so you could keep doing two thousands
three thousands four thousands two
thousand eighteen hundred fifteen
hundred twenty three hundred and and
replicate success uh you know some
people say experience is the best
teacher
it's not true experience is not the best
teacher evaluated experience is the best
teacher we have to become Masters at
analyzing not just YouTube analytics but
analyzing content analyzing our audience
retention curve analyze analyzing
feedback signals analyzing the topic
listening to comments thinking about
viewer psychology
experience is not the best teacher
evaluated experience is the best teacher
because when you mine not just general
success principles but your own formula
for your own Niche and your own content
and then you repeat success a lot of
people have accidental success and they
don't know how to repeat it two things
number one I've had too much coffee
today number two if you have not seen
our free master class yet you're gonna
love it if you're serious about growing
your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class